do you believe that the government
believes that they understand what's
going on behind the UFO
phenomenon
no so they realize that they don't know
what's going on or you think that they
think that they have a handle on it I
think that there's probably a number of
you know how in the United States we
have different we have Democrats and
Republicans and things like that I think
that the government is pretty much the
space program is like that there are
different factions within it and some of
them are tasked with trying to figure
this out and some of them think they
know what it is about and some of them
know Well we don't know what this is
about